Dave is with us in Michigan hi Dave
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thank you for everything you do I'm a
huge fan of your show
I'm honored thank you how can I help hey
so my wife and I are in baby steps evan
has really appreciated your help over
the years and feel like we live in the
dream but I have a work-related question
for you so we had the option the
privilege I suppose some would say a
little incorporating an ex-colored oh we
got bought out yeah so I of course
declined I haven't owned the car in like
ten years yeah and instead I just you
know I incur expenses you know flights
and hotels are paid directly by the
company but everything else I just put
on my debit card expensive everything's
fine
but we just got an email saying that
this trailing budget that we've had it's
about three thousand dollars per year
and I can attend like technical
conferences or basically anything I want
for professional development and we got
this email saying there's this new
requirement you have to use the MX to
pay for those trainings so I'm not going
to get the I don't even know if I can
get the M excellent okay I'm not even
planning on that but I also don't want
to not take advantage of this benefit so
just hoping you had a thought of what I
might be able to do I suppose I could
ask my manager if you would pay for it
he wants the miles but I feel we're
doing no unless you can pay for it
personally but unless for him to waive
the policy the policy is ridiculous
right I mean just get an exception of
the policy how large your companies is
the parent company is about a hundred
thousand people the Senate that's who
sent out the email or the subsidiary did
it our company sent the email but it's
like come down from corporate
essentially yeah well as you know the
problem with the corporate AMEX card is
you're personally liable I had heard
that I think I read that on some around
your site yeah and it's
it's a piece of crap it's an absolutely
horrible product and the fact that
corporate America has gotten duped by
those people is unbelievable now they're
there it's a bad company and a bad
product
yeah I'd stay away from it I hope you
can figure this out but um or at least
they'll reimburse you if you pay for it
my gosh right you know you've got well
you got the money you're a baby step
seven you're not hurting for money but I
mean I wouldn't want to just come out of
pocket and pay to be trained when nobody
else would being paid to be trained they
can they can do this you know if
somebody else has got a corporate Amex
they could run yours on it that's fine
because that's a company paying it as
long as the company pays it you know
they don't have a problem right yeah so
a lot of people just don't perceive this
risk and I've had people with these
corporate Amex cards when the company
went sideways or just decided they were
going to now the charges they come after
the individual and it's just and it's a
bad situation so I'm not I'm not signing
up for that under any circumstances but
my hope is you can just give it away you
know give you an exception to the policy
wouldn't be that unusual just say you
know I got one weird employee over here
doesn't borrow money and you know he
just wants to be reimbursed and okay
yeah he's a good guy he's great on
everything else and so he just got this
one weird quirk because he doesn't
borrow money you know and you probably
can get an exception depending on how
whacked-out your your group is that
you're working for but I was I don't
know how to solve it other than that
maybe you know possibly someone put it
on the corporate mx that's the worst
option the best options you get an
exception and then the other option is
just not do the training which is not a
good that's not a good option but I'm
not taking out the AMEX for it not a
chance